la gestion des eaux pluviales ce n'est
pas une contrainte mais c'est plutôt une
opportunité pour la ville pour les
résidents on peut créer des aménagements
vraiment très intéressants plein de du
design au plan d'architecture du paysage
donc il faut changer nos façons
d'aménager nos villes
[Musique]
je trouve présentement à la Place Fleur
de macadam qui a été créé comme un
espace public inondable ce qu'on appelle
chez nous place résiliente ça vient du
concept de Water square qui a été
développé par une firme de design urbain
à Rotterdam la ville de Rotterdam s'est
rendu compte que pour faire face au
changement climatique ils auraient
besoin d'un énorme bassin de rétention
pour pouvoir capter le surplus de pluie
donc ce qui a été décidé c'est plutôt de
construire cet énorme bassin valait
mieux le disséminer à travers la ville
donc de créer plein d'espaces publics
qui puissent être inondable
généralement les parcs et des places
publiques sont souvent de forme convexe
donc l'eau a tendance à s'écouler vers
l'extérieur du parc pour les plus
fréquentes ça pose pas tellement de
problèmes à peu près l'ensemble du
ruissellement capté par le réseau mais
lorsqu'il y a des pluies très intenses
malheureusement est tellement grande que
le réseau des goûts est plus capable de
capter ces eaux là et donc il continue
sa route inévitablement il va se diriger
vers les points bas
par exemple le 16 juin 2022 on a eu plus
de 60 à 70 mm de pluie en espace de 6
heures et ça crée vraiment des
inondations locales à plusieurs endroits
notamment des viaducs mais aussi dans
des secteurs résidentiels donc l'idée
était d'inverser les choses et donc de
faire en sorte que les parcs deviennent
des zones concave qui puissent capter le
surplus d'eau pour réduire la pression
sur les réseaux d'égouts et sur les
infrastructures
les enfants partent en sec peuvent
s'amuser peuvent déambuler sur des
différents parcours là de Pierre partant
de pluie très intense dans ces
espaces-là de servent à capter de
ruissellement excessif pour éviter des
inondations en aval
à Montréal donc on a le parc Pierre
Dansereau on a ici la place publique
fleur de macadam on a deux autres parcs
aussi qui ont été réalisés on en a
presque une dizaine d’autres là qui
s'enviennent il faut savoir qu'ici
c'était un ancienne station-service
tandis qu'au Parc Pierre Dansereau
c'était une ancienne cour de triage donc
ces espaces qui étaient pas du tout
dédiés aux bénéfice de la population ont
pu être transformés pour en faire des
espaces vraiment agréables
utile à la population
il y a beaucoup d'autres villes aussi
qui sont en train de développer des
concepts similaires on parle on parle de
plus en plus de ville éponges par
exemple donc partout on peut capter le
ruissellement excessif pour faire face
justement aux pluies extrêmes au plus
innuient qui vont survenir de plus en
plus souvent du fait des changements
climatiques
les places résilientes c'est vraiment
une occasion de mise en scène de l'eau
donc on voit que c'est très apprécié
puis je pense que plus on va en
développer plus des gens vont apprécier
puis vont avoir le goût de l'eau